a may day march is also set to happen
this evening on the las vegas strip it
starts near valleys and organizers say
they're demanding stronger worker
protections and advocating for
immigration rights mary jane belliesa
joins us live near flamingo and las
vegas boulevard with the details tonight
mary jane
saucer good evening that march is
expected to get underway here in just
shortly here around 6 15 now a number of
community organizations are gathering
here near the bellagio fountains this
may is also known for international
workers day in las vegas immigrant
workers and community members are
marching to demand a pathway to
citizenship and permanent protections a
number of organizations will be in
attendance including make the road
nevada and the national domestic workers
alliance just to name a few they hope
their voices will be heard as they fight
for the many immigrant workers who call
america home
we're
organizing with
union organizations labor organizations
and immigrant advocacy groups to
celebrate
immigrant workers celebrate
union workers and also
we're here to
demand that president biden keep his
campaign promise in providing a
permanent pathway to citizenship for
undocumented families
[Music]
here live ocapa also has a total of four
organizations that will be here and he
says for this march they are expecting
around 150 people total now this march
will continue through about 7 15 7 30
and those in attendance hope to show
that nevada is a welcoming place for
immigrants reporting live from the strip
mary jane vallieza live local now